Your device has a pretty nifty developer
option for showing GPU overdraw.
Once you toggle back to active,
you'll notice that your layouts
are all drawn with a tint.
A pixel drawn once is
shown in its normal color.
But when the pixel is drawn over itself,
it's tinted.
You've got blue for one overdraw, green
for two, pink for three and red for
four or more.
Clearly, the goal here is to
minimize the amount of red, and
keep everything fairly blue.
To see how this works,
we'll look at Sunshine both before and
after Dan updated it with a look
inspired by Material Design.
You'll notice that most things
are pretty consistent, except that
after material, everything is a shade or
two darker on the tint scale.
This is because material design focuses
on beautiful components and transitions.
And so
it comes with a heavier drawing cost.
Some events have a heavier cost as well.
Clicking, for example,
tends to result in a shading effect as
an indicator of the action to the user.
You can see this with a red
overdraw on a touch event.
With material design, though,
we increase the number of these types of
smaller overdraws with the addition of
animations, such as the scroll animation
or the hover action in the menu.
These animation elements add
a bit of magic to the app and
help create a beautiful user experience,
but as you've seen,
there's clearly a rendering cost.
Perf considerations are a trade-off.
You want to do fancy things, but
you might be doing too much, so
use your tools to set up
a regular testing process and
then evaluate why your changes for the
better versus how it could be improved.